hey wassup guys my name is Jonah welcome
back to the third and final part of my
reaction / review of the road to PS 5
video I'm super excited to finish this
presentation today so let's just jump
into it and take a look at what else is
in store we just go back a little bit I
guess we're offering cow consumption
always which is at about 33 minutes and
15 or so seconds the best job link will
be missed or eclis our process for
setting CPU and GPU frequencies has
relied on some heavy duty guesswork with
regards to how much electrical power
games will consume and how much heat
will be produced as a result inside this
is really interesting as well because I
used to work at EA as most of you know
and specifically I spent most of my time
working on mobile games and mobile games
have a very similar kind of set of
requirements to this in in in in terms
of power consumption
you know thermal issues all of that
stuff is very very much a big deal in
that space it's interesting because it's
not really just a matter of can this
device play this game at like 30 or 60
frames per second its how long can it do
that for before it either overheats or
because it because of thermal throttling
like the CPU or the GPU has to like
scale back its clock speed there's all
of these kind of surrounding issues not
even just about can the hardware
physically do this it's is it
sustainable how much power consumption
is gonna use and how much heat is it
going to going to introduce so this is
the console it's interesting to hear
that they're basically battling with the
same issues and how much heat will be
produced as a result inside of the
console power consumption varies a lot
from game to game when I play god of war
on my ps4 Pro I know the power
consumption is high just by the fan
noise but power isn't simply about
engine quality it's about the minutiae
of what's being displayed and how it's
counterintuitive but processing dense
geometry typically consumes less power
than processing simple geometry which is
I suspect why horizons map screen with
its low triangle count makes my ps4 pro
heat up so much that's interesting cBS
consoles has been to try to guess what
the maximum power consumption during the
higher console lifetime not B which is
to say the worst case seen in the worst
case game and prepare a cooling solution
that we think will be quiet at that
power level if we get it right fan noise
is minimal if we get it wrong the
console will be quite loud for the
higher power games and there's even a
chance that it might overheat and shut
down if we miss estimate power too badly
mm-hmm PlayStation 5 is especially
challenging because the CPU supports 256
bit native instructions that consume a
lot of power these are great here and
there but presumably only minimally used
or are they if we plan for major 256 bit
instruction usage we need to set the CPU
clock substantially lower or noticeably
increase the size of the power supply
and Finn mm-hmm so after much discussion
we decided to go with a very different
direction on PlayStation 5 we built a
GPU with 36c use mind you our DNA to see
use our large each has 62% more
transistors than the ceus we were using
on PlayStation 4 so if we compare
transistor counts 36 our DNA to see use
equates to roughly 58 PlayStation 4 C
use it is a fairly sizable GPU then we
went with a variable frequency strategy
for PlayStation 5 which is to say we
continuously run the GPU and CPU in
boost mode we supply a generous amount
of electrical power and then increase
the frequency of GPU and CPU until they
reach the capabilities of the system's
cooling solution it's a completely
different paradigm rather than running
at constant frequency and letting power
vary based on the workload we run at
essentially constant power and let the
frequency band vary based on the
workload yes so that that's solving that
whole problem of like what happens when
we have a very light scene we don't have
much actual computing power required
because we don't have like a
particularly dense piece of geometry as
he was saying because in those cases
what happens is the PlayStation still
going kind of at full blast because
that's what it's that's how the hardware
works but here what he's saying is that
during the lighter load C
they can actually reduce the frequency
because they don't need that processing
power and they can maybe boost it in
other areas supposedly but in heavier
scenes they can kind of increase that
frequency so that's that's an
interesting way of looking at it's kind
of like an in Reverse and it's
ultimately probably going to provide
just a nicer general solution we doesn't
tackle the engineering challenge of a
cost-effective and high-performance
cooling solution designed for that
specific power level in some ways it
becomes a simpler problem because there
are no more unknowns there's no need to
guess what power consumption the worst
case game might have as for the details
of the cooling solution we're saving
them for our teardown I think you'll be
quite happy with what the engineering
team came up with ok how fast can we run
the GPU
what's this teardown thing ones that
happen CPU the strategy the simplest
approach would be to look at the actual
temperature of the silicon die and
throttle the frequency on that basis but
that won't work it fails to create a
consistent playstation 5 experience yeah
that's also like difficult to do because
throttling frequency is based on
temperature that's how games will
eventually like drop framerate and it
will just start taking every frame will
start taking longer because they have to
dial back the clock frequencies because
the device is like overheating that's
not generally a good thing to do it's
it's it I mean it's either that or just
overheat and then shut down the whole
console but in general obviously it's
not an ideal solution it's definitely
something we used to battle with all the
time with various like Android devices
it wouldn't do to run a console slower
simply because it was in a hot room
easily rather than look at the actual
temperature of the silicon die we look
at the activities that the GPU and CPU
are performing and set the frequencies
on that basis which makes everything
deterministic and repeatable mm-hmm
while we're at it we also use AMD's
smart shift that doesn't change the fact
that the room might be hotter though and
I'm not sure how the hardware is going
to adapt to that but generally like you
know looking into the activity and being
a little bit more informed I guess about
what's actually going on with the hard
way is obviously a smarter way of doing
all of this technology and send anyone
using
to the GPU so it can squeeze out a few
more pixels the benefits of this
strategy are quite large it creates a
more balanced overall system running a
GPU at two gigahertz was looking like an
unreachable target with the old fixed
frequency strategy with this new
paradigm we're able to run way over that
in fact we have to cap the GPU frequency
at two point to three gigahertz so that
we can guarantee that the on chip logic
operates properly they're getting up to
the point where it is running too fast
for the logic to actually work out is
36c use at two point two three gigahertz
is ten point three teraflops and we
expect the GPU to spend most of its time
at or close to that frequency and
performance similarly running the CPU at
three gigahertz was causing headaches
with the old strategy but now we can run
it as high as 3.5 gigahertz in fact it
spends most of its time at that
frequency that doesn't mean all games
will be running at two point to three
gigahertz and 3.5 gigahertz when that
worst case game arrives
it will run at a lower clock speed but I
just wanted to say that like I don't
generally like looking at numbers like
this because I don't know in my
experience like it looking at at like
clock speeds and frequencies and
teraflops and all of that stuff it's
it's fine and it might look good on
paper but when you actually start
programming for that hardware and you
start stress testing it and you have an
actual full game that you've built up
which is a difficult thing to do it's
not something you can get to within a
few months of just having this new ps5
hardware when you finally get to that
stage you may notice problems and and
again numbers are fine it's cool that it
meets certain specifications but to be
honest like that means nothing until you
can actually see that in practice so I
don't know what would just you know this
is just my opinion and my thoughts but
when I look at these numbers it's very
difficult for me to be like oh though it
is a lot better like when I look at SSD
spades and it says like you know five
gigabytes a second or whatever like that
that's a that's an amount that I'm sure
that the console could sustain and I can
actually you know picture myself
streaming
five gigabytes per second that's like
something tangible but a clock speed and
you know a teraflop count I just for me
personally at least is a little bit
harder to look at that and be like oh I
can draw this many triangles oh I can
make a game that suddenly supports this
because until I start programming for
that hardware and I see what other
people have done and how sustainable it
is and all of that stuff it's very
difficult to just you know see kind of a
specific how should I say this a
specific upgrade in a particular
department even though obviously the
numbers are the numbers are there but
there's a bit more of a disconnect I
feel between those numbers and what's
actually capable of being achieved on
that platform not too much lower to
reduce power by 10% it only takes a
couple of percent reduction in frequency
so I'd expect any down clocking to be
pretty minor all things considered the
change to a variable frequency approach
will show significant gains for
PlayStation gamers the final of our
three principles was about finding new
dreams it's important for us on the
hardware team to find new ways to expand
or deepen gaming and that's what led us
to a focus on 3d audio as players we
experience the game through the visuals
this what it like as a musician as well
like I really like what here and audios
always like something that I very much
notice in games and that I really enjoy
so this is exciting to me as well even
though I spend a majority of my
programming time working on graphics and
rendering like related features through
audio and through the feedback we
received from the controller such as
Rumble or haptics personally I feel a
game is just dead without audio visuals
are horse important but the impact of
audio is huge as well at the same time
the audio team on a game project has to
do a lot with a little for example on
PlayStation 4 there's fierce competition
for the Jaguar CPU cores audio typically
ends up getting just a fraction of a
core that's not much of a computational
resource particularly when you consider
that the visuals run at 30 or 60 frames
a second but audio processing needs to
happen at almost 200 times
second so it's been tough going making
forward progress on audio with
Playstation 4
particularly when PlayStation 3 was such
a beast when it came to audio the SPU's
and cell were almost a perfect device
for audio rendering simple pipeline
algorithms could really take advantage
of asynchronous DMA and frequently
reached a hundred percent utilization of
the floating-point unit there's
unfortunately nothing comparable on
PlayStation 4 probably the most dramatic
progress in the PlayStation 4 generation
has been with Virtual Reality
the PSD our hardware has its own audio
unit it supports about 50 pretty decent
3d sound sources and this provided a
hint as to where we could go with audio
as well as some valuable experience not
to oversimplify but here were our goals
for audio on PlayStation such a crazy
animation that's cool the first goal was
great audio for everyone not just a VR
it's funny how the audio like part of
this presentation has it's like amazing
visuals users or sound bar owners or
headphone users that meant audio had to
be part of the console it couldn't be a
peripheral the second goal was to
support hundreds of sound sources we
didn't want developers to have to pick
and choose what sounds would get 3d
effects interesting to listen to we
wanted every sound in the game to have
dimensionality and finally we wanted to
really take on the challenges of
presence and locality now when we say
presence we mean the feeling that you're
actually there you've entered the matrix
immersion is like it's so important for
imagine like if you're trying to immerse
your player in your game and the audio
isn't is an on point and their music or
the ambience and just all of the kind of
sound design is not on point it's very
difficult to do and that's why I like
visuals are great and all but if you
don't have things like you was talking
about haptic feedback for controllers
and you know the actual audio sound
design as I mentioned that stuff goes so
far in terms of immersion I'd go to say
that if you're not dealing with like a
virtual reality headset if you close
your eyes and just listen to the sound
design that can immerse you a lot more
that you
looking at a TV and just or a computer
screen and being like oh cool these
visuals look real it's not of course
something we thought we could perfectly
achieve the idea was that if we stopped
using just a rain sound and instead use
lots of 3d audio sources for raindrops
hitting the ground and all sorts of
locations around you then at some point
your brain would take a leap and you'd
begin to have this feeling this feeling
of real presence inside the virtual
world of the game this has the capacity
to affect your appreciation of the game
just like music in a game does for sure
the concept of locality is simpler it's
just your sense of where the audio is
coming from to the right of you behind
you above you this can immerse you
further in the game and it can also
directly enhance the gameplay to use
dead space as an example I know old
school you're fighting enemies in fairly
dark spooky locations back in the day if
you played the game using the TV
speakers you could tell that there was
one last enemy growling and hunting you
down but it was difficult to tell quite
where that enemy was with headphones you
could tell that the enemy was somewhere
on the right which lets you deduce if
you couldn't see it that it must be
somewhere behind and to your right but
with 3d audio with good locality the
idea is you know the enemy is precisely
there and you turn and you take it out
so how do we know where a sound is
coming from in the first place well all
those bumps and folds in the ear have a
meaning evolutionarily speaking based on
what direction the sound is coming from
sound waves bounce around inside the ear
there's some constructive and
destructive interference and the result
is a change in volume the phase of the
sound also shifts depending on what path
the Soundwave took to reach the ear
canal these volume changes and phase
shifts are different for each direction
and also vary depending on the frequency
of the sound head size and head shape
also impact the sound in a similar
fashion it's also like the environment
also matters a lot because sound
reflects off of a lot of different
materials and that can definitely create
some kind of phase phasing issues and
all of these things that
in terms like it your brain will
eventually construct that into something
way that the sounds changes based on
direction and frequency can be encoded
in a table called the head related
transfer function or HR TF here's part
of one the vertical axis is the
frequency the horizontal axis is the
direction front back left right and the
color gives the degree of attenuation of
the sound at that frequency the HR TF is
as unique to an individual as a
fingerprint is in fact you're looking at
mine right now here is how we measure NH
RTF we've taken hundreds of people
through this process we put a microphone
in the subjects left and right ear
canals and then sit the subject down in
the middle of an array of 22 speakers
they're basically measuring the
acoustical properties in terms of like
the actual physical acoustical space
inside someone's ear to determine how
they hear which is we then play an audio
tape from each speaker as we rotate the
subject in the course of ten or twenty
minutes we're able to sample the HR TF
at over 1,000 locations using an HR TF
when rendering audio creates
unparalleled quality but it's
computationally expensive the simplest
way to use an HR TF is to process a
sound source to make it appear as if
it's coming from one of those thousand
locations we sample unfortunately the
processing has to be done in frequency
domain rather than time domain so
there's multiple fast Fourier transforms
needed for every sound source for every
audio tech that's a lot of multiplies
this computational complexity was the
determining factor for our strategy and
we had to bite the bullet and design and
build a custom hardware unit for 3d
audio collection that's what I was
expecting
basically we're referring to the
hardware unit and the proprietary
algorithms we run on it as tempest 3d
audio tech the meaning of 3d audio and
technology should be pretty op with the
visuals as for tempest I feel it really
reflects our goals with audio it
suggests a certain intensity of
experience and also hints at your
presence within it we're calling the
hardware unit that we built the tempest
engine it's based on AMD's GP
new technology we modified a compute
unit in such a way as to make it very
close to the SPU's in playstation 3
remember when I said that they were
ideal for audio so the tempest engine
has no caches just like an SPU all data
access is via DMA just like an SPU our
target was that it would have more power
than a CPU thanks to the parallelism
that a GPU can achieve and then it would
be more efficient than our GPU thanks to
the SPU like architecture the goal being
to make possible near 100% utilization
of the see use vector units where we
ended up is a unit with roughly the same
Cindy power and bandwidth as all eight
Jaguar cores in the PlayStation 4
combined if we were to use the same
algorithms as psvr that's enough for
something like five so the basic with
vectorization everything they're just
talking about how they've designed a
unit that's capable of doing a whole
large amount of multiplies which there's
like Fourier transforms and all that
stuff required to do all the audio so
it's a very it's basically like a
powerful like multiplication chip that's
capable of doing essentially what the
audio what the audio needs thousand
sound sources but of course we as VR
that's enough for something like 5,000
5,000 but of course we want to use more
complex algorithms and we don't need
anything like that number of sounds it
would have been wonderful if a simpler
strategy such as using Dolby Atmos
peripherals could have achieved our
goals but we wanted 3d audio for all not
just those with licensed sound bars or
the like also we wanted many hundreds of
sound sources not just the 32 that at
most supports and finally we wanted to
be able to throw an overwhelming amount
of processing power at the problem and
it wasn't clear what any peripheral
might have inside of it in fact with the
tempest engine we've even got enough
power that we can allocate some to the
games to the extent that games want to
make use of convolution reverb and other
algorithms that are either
computationally expensive or need high
bandwidth but the primary purpose of the
tempest engine remains 3d audio now 3d
audio is a major
academic research topic it's safe to say
that no one in the world has all of the
answers and the set of algorithms that
has to be invented tuned or implemented
to realize our vision for 3d audio is
immense for example use of HR TFS and
games is quite complex before I talked
about making a sound source appear as if
it's coming from one of those thousand
HR TF sample locations but for
high-quality 3d game audio we have to
handle other possibilities the sound
source might not be at one of the
thousand HR TF sample locations so we
have to blend the HR TF data from the
closest locations that we have sampled
the sound source might be moving which
needs very special handling as that
blend keeps changing and that can cause
phase artifacts in the resulting audio
or the sound source might have a size to
it meaning it should feel as if it's
coming from an area rather than a single
point there's also whole categories of
approaches to be handled 3d audio can be
implemented using individual processing
of 3d sound sources but alternatively
ambisonics can be used for 3d audio
ambisonics speak somewhat like the
spherical harmonics used in computer
graphics and finally there's audio
devices the player might be using
headphones or TV speakers or have a
higher-end surround sound set up with
six or more speakers all of which need
different approaches that's a lot of
variations it's nice to have the
computational resources of the tempest
engine but it's clear that achieving our
ultimate goals with 3d audio is going to
be a multi-year step-by-step process
having said that headphone audio
implementation is largely complete at
this time it was a natural place for us
to start with headphones we control
exactly what each ear hears and
therefore the algorithmic development
and implementation are more
straightforward for TV speakers and
stereo speakers were in the process of
implementing virtual surround sound the
idea being that if you're sitting in a
sweet spot in front of the TV
then the sound can be made to feel as if
it's coming from any direction even
behind you
virtual surround sound has a lot in
common with 3d audio on headphones but
it's more complex because the left ear
can hear the right
speaker and vice-versa we have a basic
implementation of virtual surround sound
up and running we're now looking at
increasing the size of that sweet spot
which is to say making the area you need
to be in to feel the 3d effect larger
and we're also working to boost the
sense of locality head yeah so this
stuff this stuff is super interesting
because they're basically talking about
emulating a whole surround sound set up
for like a TV or something where you
just have kind of two speakers in front
of you how can they make that feel like
surround sound meaning happen they make
that feel as if you've got speakers all
around and in which case you could
actually like literally send sound to
particular speakers that you know are
behind the player to make it feel like
something's coming from behind rather
than in front
they're basically emulating that for a
two kind of front facing speaker
situation which is super cool and I
really would be interested to to hear
exactly how this stuff sounds it reminds
me a little bit of like the the Nintendo
3ds and how they were able to kind of
you know deal with like a 3d display
that didn't require glasses phone audio
is the current gold standard for 3d
audience basically just based on tricks
and stuff but it's super interesting on
PlayStation 5 but we're going to see
what we can do to bring virtual surround
sound to a similar level after which
we'll start in on setups with more
speakers such as 6 channel surround set
which is always it's not at the point
where some of the PlayStation 5 games in
development are extensively using these
systems one of the game demos allows you
to toggle between conventional
PlayStation 4 style stereo audio and our
new 3d audio I listened with just an
ordinary pair of over the year
headphones and wow I could feel a
difference 3d audio has that dimensional
feel to it conventional stereo audio
feels smashed flat by comparison the
improvement is obvious it's probably
like going from mono to stereo and then
now going from stereo to 3d you so
interested a big advancement by super
cool have I entered matrix does my brain
believe I'm really there like I was
talking about earlier when I explained
our target a presence well the answer
isn't no but you've probably caught on
to what's missing here namely who's HRT
F was being used
it wasn't mine it was the default HRT F
the audio team analyzed the hundreds
that they measured and chose the one
they felt with the closest fit to the
total game playing audience
this shows a a piece of the default HRT
F on the left and my HRT F on the right
you can see that the general features
are much the same but the details are
quite different soon they'll be asking
people to go to a lab they won't like
the the next-generation audio they'll
have to rock up at a lab to get their
ears analyzed with the default HRT alpha
now because 3d audio sounds pretty great
when I use my HRT F though the audio
reaches a higher level of realism which
is to say that when using headphones and
my HRT F I occasionally get fooled and
even think a sound is coming from the
real world when it's actually coming
from the game yeah that's the level you
want to be at the level that makes you
take off your headphones and be like
what oh oh that was part of the game
corollary to this is that there are a
few people whose HRT FS are sufficiently
far from the default HRT F that's the
red dot here that they can toggle
between ps4 style and PS v style audio
and not sense much difference I've had a
few people describe the PlayStation v 3d
audio is sounding like a bit better
stereo audio presumably they're the ones
at the very edges of this diagram which
means what HRT F you're using is key I'd
like everyone to be able to experience
what I'm experiencing but obviously it's
not possible to measure the HRT F of
every PlayStation user that means HRT F
selection and synthesis are going to be
big topics going forward as the tempest
technology matures at PlayStation 5
launch will be offering a choice of five
HRT FS there's a simple test where you
pick the one that gives you the best
locality that's just the first step
though this is an open-ended research
topic maybe you'll be sending us a photo
of your ear and we'll choose a neural
network to pick the closest HRT F in our
library maybe you'll be sending us a
video of your ears and your head and
we'll make a 3d model of them in
synthesis amazing HRT F
audio game to tune your HRT F will be
subtly changing it as you play and home
in on the
char TF that gives you the highest score
you know that it matches you the best
this is a journey we'll all be taking
together over the next few years
ultimately we're committing to enabling
everyone to experience that next level
of realism hopefully I've been able to
illustrate a bit about our design and
decision making process today and why
PlayStation 5 has the feature set that
it does now comes the fun part we get to
see how the development community takes
advantage of that feature set and be
promoting for the completely unexpected
will it come from audio ray-tracing the
capabilities of the SSD or something
else I guess we'll find out soon enough
thank you for your time today there you
go
wow that's so much stuff here to talk
about um yeah like what he said at the
end I think I'll just kind of mention
this in closing that what he said at the
end about now it's time for the
development community to basically take
hold of this and we'll see what what
they create and I'll probably just be
completely unexpected and that's what
he's hoping for it's gonna take a long
time until we realize the full potential
of this new platform just like it is
with any new platform and just like it
has been with every single PlayStation
and other console you know throughout
history it's it's definitely gonna take
a few years to mature I'm really
interested to see what they're able to
achieve now I know for a fact that like
companies like PlayStation Xbox and you
know Oldham all those kind of consoles
they are working a lot more closely with
developers now than they ever have
before which is really good it means
that they can hopefully start cutting
down as he mentioned earlier in the
presentation that kind of time to first
triangle where no one has any idea how
to get started with a new platform
that's being cut down hopefully we'll
see a more rapid progression in platform
maturity from something like this but in
general I honestly I'm super excited to
see what people are going to come up
with for this platform I think that the
possibilities are going to be very much
endless
and we'll be able to see a lot of really
cool content that probably wouldn't have
otherwise been possible I hope you guys
enjoyed this reaction and just my
thoughts on this Playstation 5
presentation it was a lot of fun to look
through this I feel a lot more informed
about the next generation of consoles
which is really good so now that we've
finished watching this road to PS 5
presentation what excites you the most
what do you think will make the hugest
impact in this new generation of
consoles leave your thoughts in the
comments section below you guys enjoyed
this video please don't forget to hit
the like button and also subscribe to
this channel if you are new for those of
you who have been part of this channel
I'm going to get back to working on my
game engine called hazel and making
videos about that as well and who knows
maybe one day hazel will support the
PlayStation 5 as well thank you guys so
much for watching I will see you next
time goodbye
[Music]
you